اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا كما قلنا
انسحاب الفرقه 36 من قطاع غزه دائما بحسب
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بقي في قطاع غزه
كما تقول الاذاعه ثلاث فرق من الجيش وهي
و12
و98 وحديث اذا عن انسحاب الفرقه ال
36 من قطاع غزه دائما في الاخبار العاجله
صحيفه اسرائيل هيوم تتحدث اذا الفرقه 36
التي انسحبت كما تقول الصحيفه من غزه تضم
اذا تقول الويه جولاني والسادس والسابع
و18 وسلاح هندسه اذا تطورات ملفته في
الواقع في ما يحصل ويدور اذا من معارك
وتطورات في قطاع غزه سنتعرف على المزيد
لاحقا في تحليل العسكري للمشهد دائما
اخبار عاجله بحسب اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
اذا بقي في قطاع غزه ثلاثه فرق من الجيش
وهي 99 و12 و98 كما سبق و ذكرنا صحيفه
اسرائيل هيوم اذا تتحدث عن الفرقه ال6
التي انسحبت من غزه وتضم اذا الويه جولاني
والسادس والسابع
و18 والسلاح هندسه
اذا